Wow Wow
I cannot believe I'm finally talking
about the Irishman don't worry in this
review I will not subject you guys to my
horrible De Niro and Pacino impressions
that I feel I do an excellent job at
when I am by myself in the car I've been
craving this movie since I was a little
kid I love mob movies in general not in
fact the only portrait painting I've
ever bought is right over there if
you'll allow me to indulge just want to
give a little bit of backstory on my
anticipation I've had for this movie
since I was a little kid the first time
I saw Goodfellas I believe I was in the
seventh grade it led me on a path of
binging Scorsese films experiencing the
glory of De Niro and Pesci sharing the
screen and films like Raging Bull
Goodfellas and Casino you guys know and
then of course there was the Al Pacino
films and this was after he had already
come out and then that movie they only
shared like ten minutes of screen time
together this was before Righteous Kill
came out which is the one we don't talk
about I hate that movie you know the way
we acknowledge Ryan Gosling and Emma
Stone in Crazy Stupid Love and lala land
but we don't really talk about their
sophomore movie Gangster Squad whatever
that is for them that's what Righteous
Kill is for De Niro and Pacino growing
up as a cinephile does sound pretentious
to call myself a cinephile yes yes it
does anyway you're not joking I'll speed
it up I remember I would watch Godfather
2 with Al Pacino as Michael Corleone De
Niro as a young Vito Corleone that just
started wanting us to see a movie with
De Niro and Pacino is sharing the screen
the whole time in a good movie not that
Righteous Kill crap it's like whenever
they would do those fades from one
storyline to the next or like but
they're never gonna cross paths in this
movie so in junior high created my own
little binge fest first I watch The
Godfather movies then I watch a solo De
Niro movie then a Pacino an engineer
movie then epigenome movies so on and so
forth all that culminates of watching
the movie heat my own little cinematic
Universal swords but let's face it as
great as heat was like a lot of people
we all knew that we'd want to see them
on screen together under the direction
of Martin Scorsese specifically a
Scorsese gangster fell and now here we
are with the Irishman Wow does it
deliver
to hell with those theme park movies no
no no they're great too so the plot
description on Wikipedia describes the
synopsis the best and frankly his name's
Frank De Niro's character's name frankly
I would just spend way too much time
trying to figure out the most concise
way to tell you the plot so I'm gonna
say right here in the 1950s truck driver
Frank Sheeran gets involved with Russell
Bufalino and his Pennsylvania crime
family as Sheeran climbs the ranks to
become a top hit man he also goes to
work for Jimmy Hoffa a powerful teamster
tied to organized crime the best way I
can describe my experience to this film
is that it gave me everything I wanted
but executed in such a different way
than I anticipated it will actually
sauce maybe a little over a week ago
shouts out to the Egyptian theater
because they did an amazing screening I
loved the introduction over the past
week there's still scenes that I'll just
randomly think about or flash to in my
own mind and they're not even like a
loud bombastic scene or something like
that or a cool scene a lot of times
they're just scenes where characters are
just contemplative or thinking or
affected by something and you're just
watching their expression those are the
scenes that I find to be like the most
effective actually in this film I think
it's important note that if you are like
a big Scorsese fan or if you like the
older gangster films he's done it's not
that it's not Goodfellas it's not casino
sure they're gonna draw comparisons
folks as a mafia characters it has a
narration from the main character that
occasionally it's Doc's directly to the
audience there's violence it spans a lot
of time so yeah like there are some
similarities on paper but it's really
very different than those movies if you
look at specifically Goodfellas and
Casino I'd even throw a wolf of
wallstreet in there those are really
really fast paced movies where a lot of
the movie specifically the first half is
dedicated to immersing you into the
glossy cool access lifestyle of being a
criminal where you can actually see the
temptations of the criminal lifestyle to
the point as a viewer like oh man that
loses a lot of great soundtracks to all
these awesome scenes and montages and
the narration is so constant in those
films to the point where it's kind of a
soundtrack of its own and in those
movies the main characters have a love
story which creates a lot of problems
for them this movie is not that there's
nothing in here that makes the criminal
lifestyle seem appealing
there's no gloss to it it space is more
meditate
it's a much more patient feel there's a
lot of moments especially with DeNiro
and a good amount with Joe Pesci and a
good amount would zero and hashish air
in the screen we just watch them think
and it's consistently compelling the way
I describe the pacing and overall style
of this film is somewhere in between the
Scorsese that paid silence and this
Scorsese who directed Goodfellas I mean
the narration isn't as heavy there's
actually a lot a lot of amazing original
music by Robbie Robertson as opposed to
a like a whole crazy playlist there's no
it's just a shot away from rolling
stones in here that wouldn't fit in this
movie in fact there's about a 20 to 30
minute sequence in the in the last like
third of this movie that has no music no
narration this is really tense build-up
and probably the most tense experience
I've had of the theaters all year I'd
say that maybe in like the first 45
minutes of this film before Jimmy Hoffa
comes into the picture there were maybe
a couple of things that's slightly
dragged to really underline that word
slight cuz it is a while before Hoffa
shows up the first third of this movie
is heavily focused on really fleshing
out the early years of Frank Sheeran and
then his relationship with Joe Pesci's
Russell Bufalino and then how their
connection eventually led into Jimmy
Hoffa and I'm not super familiar with a
real-life story of Jimmy Hoffa but I do
know that a big part of the mystique at
one point in time he just vanished
presumably murdered a lot of theories
about who killed him or what happened to
him you know I've been going around for
years and it added to his legacy but
then today no one really knows what
happened to him so factoring that into
this movie because the movie is explores
that so I don't know how much of it is
actually true or not but in terms of
storytelling it is an excellent work of
art it moves about like three and a half
hours but it really earns that runtime
it's all through the perspective of our
Irishman Frank Sheeran you really get to
explore his life before getting involved
with the Mafia how he got involved with
the Mafia the most major events of that
time the relationships he formed and
then you even focus a lot post major
events into his elderly years it's
weirdly like a slice-of-life film with a
Scorsese gangster backdrop so with the
pace and runtime it turns into a movie
that I can only describe as reflective
through its characters it explores
themes of
father Brotherhood legacy regret loss
betrayal the consequences of the choices
that we make the impact and lingering
gravity of choices that we may not at
the time have realized would be so
utterly life-changing what I've also
found very fascinating with this movie
is it really explores the question of
how much of what we did or do will
really be remembered will it really
matter in our later years how will it
affect us as human beings most of us
don't live the lifestyle of these kinds
of criminals but yet it still poises the
question to us and a bit especially than
that I mean Scorsese is my favorite
director he's been incredibly consistent
over the decades it seems like every era
he makes some defining film of that
decade and he always matures as a
director and especially shows on screen
with this movie I don't think this
should be his last movie but I could
definitely see it being his last
gangster film and I would be a-okay with
that it's like a great culmination of
all his work I mean that being said I
don't think you need to see other
Scorsese films in order to appreciate
and perhaps even love this movie however
I think the idea of feeling Scorsese
reflecting on his own past work can only
be felt if you've seen his past work you
know the end of that sentence a little
tease I can give you into what I mean by
that and whether it's intentional or not
this is kind of how I connected with
certain moments then felt re-examined by
the filmmaker there's a scene in
Goodfellas when Ray Liotta finds out his
girlfriend was hit by her neighbor and
it's also like one of the most badass
scenes of all time not like her getting
hey your hearings I would never say her
getting you know one turns out it's from
Ray Liotta drops his girlfriend off
grabs a gun and one long shot crosses
the street beats the neighbor threatens
him and asked his girlfriend hi the
weapon now from our perspective and even
his girlfriend's perspective she's drawn
to him yeah it's illegal dangerous scary
but it's also a learning because hey
look at him protecting her and I'll tell
you being a young lad in seventh grade I
was like I want to grow up and be that
kind of man to a woman and I am
show badge but very early on in this
movie this is not really a spoiler but
I'm gonna go to detail about it there's
Mon that kind of reflects something
similar in terms of like a scene and
plot point that I thought would evoke
the same kind of response but this time
it's of always frank and his daughter
witnessing an act of protection through
violence by the end of what is kind of a
similar scene it doesn't feel cool or
badass it actually feels like this is
traumatizing and scary for a loved one
to witness if you've seen the movie you
know what I mean if you haven't you will
know what I'm talking about because I
think what Scorsese films like you know
Goodfellas Casino wolf of wallstreet
there's so much of that luxurious greedy
excess lifestyle explore that even
though those films have endings in a way
that are telling you what they did
wasn't cool it's still easy to walk away
thinking it's pretty freakin cool most
of us think of like the cool stuff that
they did in those movies they're still
memes of DiCaprio and wolf of wallstreet
I see all the time on social media from
like influencer entrepreneurs and like
he was bad though the Irishman is not
that you will not walk away with that
effect it shows you early on and
throughout how much of an emotional toll
this can be on the individuals involved
and the people in these individuals
lives that by the end of this movie
which has this beautiful haunting light
like wow wouldn't a great last shot at
harking it to like the great last shot
of the Godfather not the same thing but
you know it's like that's the best
comparison I could make I felt sorry for
these characters not one part of me
wishes I could have had any
participation in the journey here so all
and often the direction of Scorsese the
writing by Steve Zaillian which is based
on a book by Charles Brandt and the
editing by longtime collaborator Thelma
Schoonmaker the filmmaking is a 10 out
of 10 do you feel the runtime sure
you're sitting for three and a half
hours you're you're bound to feel of the
runtime did it feel that long definitely
not really I'm asking you that when I
know most people are gonna watch this at
home on Netflix which is OK which is
totally fine I'll be watching it on
Netflix please don't be on your phone
even though it doesn't feel like
three-and-a-half hours it so requires a
patient viewer they let scenes ruminate
you explore these friendships these
lifestyles they let the plot slowly
envelop and it also has a surprising
amount of heart like these are tough
intimidating characters played by some
of the toughest tough guys in Hollywood
but each performer has such sincerity
and care to their portrayal Joe Pesci
surprised the hell at him the guy was
retired he came out of retirement for
this movie and of course he's an amazing
actor we all know that but his portrayal
of Russell Bufalino is not what we've
seen in Goodfellas in Cocina it's more
reserved
that's patient it's sincere its
sympathetic yet very cold you could feel
this man cares but is definitely haunted
by his own demons
it was so layered in every moment and
man his scenes with DeNiro mm mucked
about I mean that's a real word De Niro
is exceptional in this film this is back
to a more quiet version of the Niro like
yeah he's a hitman he paints houses as
they call it he's a tough guy in this
movie but there's some type of strange
innocence he brings to the characters
eyes in this move a strange mix of
detached yet compassion and sensitive
soft yet can be a bulldozer
do I sound more pretentious than I did
earlier that's not okay
and this is easily the best performance
I've seen of Al Pacino in a motion
picture in a very long time I haven't
seen the HBO movies he's done as of late
but in terms of like going to the
theaters this is the best I've seen him
in a long time and he's doing more of
what we'd expect from Pacino he's very
expressive he's a loud character but
he's not always that way in this movie
there are some moments that are very
somber quiet a lot of great tension
filled moments with him both him and
Pacino bring a sort of boyish quality to
their roles in certain scenes and
watching this man's powerful descent and
fear of losing his legacy made for
another surprising portrayal where I I
felt pity for him in a weird way I was
sympathetic to all these you know
characters were technically not good
people to the three main players we came
here to see all give 10 out of 10
performances easily I didn't know what
I'd want out of scene De Niro and Pacino
share the screen together in a gangster
film but what we got was the formation
of two men slowly becoming best friends
and it's awesome it's unexpected I loved
I kid you not there are moments I felt
hurt and heartbreak I certainly expected
to feel tension
I expected to be enamored by everything
on a filmmaking scale there's certainly
walked in
expecting to admire some intense
dramatic performances but I felt a lot
more emotions than I anticipated there's
this wonderful relationship with DeNiro
and his daughter where there's really
not a lot of dialogue between them Anna
Paquin plays the older version of his
daughter visually we just watched this
relationship become more and more
distant she obviously knows or it has a
pretty good idea of what he probably
does for a living he's doing it for his
family yet it's pushing his family away
it's wonderfully complex that whole
relationship is done in such a quiet way
it's really like the tone poem moments
of this film the supporting cast is
wonderful - Ray Romano is hilarious but
blends right in it doesn't feel like
he's in a comedy Jesse Plemons is a few
great moments where he gets really shine
rates he and Harvey Keitel back in a
Scorsese film awesome scene and have a
scene with a Nero and Pesci this guy
really should be talked about Steven
Graham who I first saw gonna be snatched
she plays a Tony Provenzano who's one of
the most focused on supporting
characters he deserves a heap ton of
praise - my one and only real criticism
with this film this is gonna be very
subjective in a different way because
it's really about how much you can
adjust or look past this for me it kept
pulling me in and out of the movie at
the beginning of a lot of scenes there's
like a lot a lot of scenes in this movie
but at the beginning of a lot of scenes
primarily in the first third of this
film which was the de-aging now the
de-aging is actually quite incredible
especially with Joe Pesci and Al Pacino
I honestly could never tell with those
two De Niro though it's kind of sad
because he's the main character there
are times where it definitely did not
look very good I mean he was clearly the
best it could be I don't think I did
myself any favors rewatching Godfather -
and Casino a few days before watching
this because I was very much well aware
of what younger versions of De Niro
actually look like Pesci and Pacino
lined up with that he did not now that
being said I feel like for a lot of
people even though it doesn't look
authentic Lee like the younger versions
of De Niro we've seen before
it's a such a constant look in the movie
it's just so damn good that I feel like
you could just adjust and accept that's
just how he looks but honestly it's
really just a small thing compared to
this grand film because as much as for
my personal views
variants that at times it was a hurl and
get past it ultimately didn't affect how
much I loved this movie I still think
the Nero is absolutely incredible I give
it a ten out of ten easily one of the
best movies of the year please go watch
alright guys thanks for watching my
review I know I'm pretty long on this
one but hey you know it some way of his
movies I was getting a lot of people
don't really watch our actual movie
reviews how many what did you think of
the Irishman dude what you want to see
De Niro Pacino do another film together
do you want Scorsese to keep doing
gangster pick just talk about anything
you want in the comment boxes hit
subscribe hit the like button click the
notification bell the video is done